IN THEIR OWN HAS HAGUE JOINING N
THE RUSH.
THE FLYERS, SMITH THE
COCONUT AND REBOUND AND HE ITS R
THE STICK O O BOARDS.
THEODORE HOLDS THE LINE.
TONIGHT.
TRYING TO SCORE!
KARLSSON.D
BETON.
THE LEAD PASS.
>> HE'S TRYING TO PO KEEGAN KOL.
OH,
AND IT'S MAX WILLMAN WITH HIS
FIRST NHL GOALAL STARTED THE CH.
AND KIND OF A LUCKY BOUNCE, GOES
RIGHT
HERE'S JANMARK DRIVING IN.
JANMARK TO THEEF
THE SEASON IN HIS NINTH IN.
A QUICK SHOT AND THEN COULDN'T
GET TO THAT SCORES!
IT'S THE FIRST IN 15
OFFENSIVELY.
KIND OF GOT CAUGHT BEHIND THE
TRAFFIC IN FRONT OF
SEASON-HIGH THREE AGAINST DALLAS
WEDNESDAY.
AND HUTTON WITH A
THIS IS THE REACTION YOU WAN
BACK TO PACIORETTY.
DOWN OF THE LEFT SIDE.
HAYES.
GIVE-AND-GO WITH WILLMAN.
GUARDING OF THE NET.
COMES OUT FRONT AND
VAN RIEMSDYK
LITTLE SHOVEL PASS TO THE SIDE.O
WORK HERE AND TRY TO CUT INTO
THE FLYER LEAD. TIGHT.
LOOKING T
TONIGHT.
STONE AND PIETRANGELO AND
PACIORET
PLAY. TRAFFIC.
LOOSE PHILLY.
THE YEAR BEFORE
MAX PACIORETTY GOES FARAR SIDE.
GOOD SCREEEE